all right so i'm going to talk about
physician of published circuit this is
joint work with rankanati stefano
tessaro and venat
van kutan
seems unfair if i pronounce everyone's
last name
it's recorded by the way
and you can never erase it
all right let's start all right the goal
of fascination in general is to compile
a program in a clear and into an
unintelligent unintelligible one while
preserving functionality
which is a very good goal and
surrounding what does unintelligible
mean there are actually many different
notions as we can see from the strongest
of virtual black box to the weakest
indistinguishability investigation and
in between there's vbp and then the io
and the own can just talk about the i o
for only uh public coin the i o
and it seems that right now still that
io is the right notion to work with
because it's weak there's no
impossibility we have candidate for it
there's active research on it and yet
it's extremely powerful okay
but nevertheless i'm going to add one
more notion to this picture
because it seems so far all the
fascination consider only deterministic
programs okay and why does it have to be
like this
and
already this need um
the definitions of those investigations
are tailored for deterministic program
as you can see already in the
correctness requirement that we actually
require that the fasta program should
preserve the functionality meaning that
for every input they will output the
same output as the original program if
you want to say this it means the
original program is deterministic
but why does it have to be
there are probabilistic programs and we
know in general they are more powerful
more general and in particular we have
lots of cryptographic algorithms which
inherently use random coins and as we
see in many applications of fascication
that we will actually like to fast it as
a part of whatever application you're
dealing with some sort of cryptographic
algorithm into it
well seems like a very natural notion
under our nose so why didn't people look
at it earlier
maybe the answer is that why bother
i mean what's so special about
probabilistic program they're just
programmed with some additional
randomness and i can view the randomness
as extra input if i do it that way it
becomes deterministic and i can just use
whatever i o that we have been using
so to see why should we bother or not
whether it deserves a paper or not
look at some motivating examples right
so here are two examples one is that
for whatever reason i would like to
publish in the first quarter program
that does oblivious sampling that
it's you can view it as i push a button
it gives me a randomly sample ddh tuple
another motivating example could be i
want to do oblivious re-encryption i
want to publish a program that's
given any cipher text this program is
going to kind of decrypt it and
re-encrypted using fresh randomness okay
seems reasonable things to
yeah if i did like the trick from the
days back to resettable
stuff and put a prf inside
with a key and apply the key to the
input and use that as a randomness that
would also be okay for these
applications right that's exactly going
to be our
construction thank you
the construction is the construction is
extremely simple
the question is what does that what kind
of property does it give us
so i thought in this left example the
point is there is no input you push the
button
yeah so but i can't really push a button
it's a program and this investigation
you will see that it's actually going to
be deterministic so the way to say that
i'm going to get many samples out of it
is to say that i'm going to input 1 and
give me 1 input 2 will give me another
one yeah so it's equivalent to saying
i'm pushing a button
all right so in both of these situations
i want two things for my random coin one
is the coin should be hidden right if
it's not hidden then what's the use of
getting those outputs from them
the other is that
i wanted the coins to be unbiased on the
other hand if i treat the coins just as
a part of the input the evaluator cannot
be truly biased the distribution of the
coin then it's again useless okay
so
this tells me that maybe
probably is the program there is
something that's non-trivial going on
okay so this work we're gonna study
indistinguishability investigation for
probabilistic programs we can show
handed as pio
and it turns out as we will see that
defining it is not straightforward and
there are a couple different variants
you can go about it and in this talk i'm
going to mainly focus on one variant
which we call xpio in the paper
we can do two things with it the first
is that we can't construct so pio h
exists so if i have subexponential io
then i can get pio i'm hiding some uh
other like assumption of one-way
function here
another thing is that i want to show you
that pio as a notion is useful
that we can actually use pio to kind of
transform any randomizable public
encryption into a fully homomorphic
encryption okay
and the neat thing about doing this is
that i don't need to rely on any
circularity assumption okay there's no
need for circular security
and
next i'm going to first to try to tell
you about the intuition of what is pio
and then a little bit about the proof of
high level of those two theorems so if
you talk about it it's just i remember
in the old days like a year ago uh
fhp from iowa was open so using your
things this is the first construction of
the fh from iowa yes
yes
extra stuff yeah from io plus extra
stuff
randomizable
you can just do for example
i need a
publicly yeah encryption
yes
yes right so you can use
no this the thing is that we want
randomizability
yeah
you can basically run imaginable so this
is sort of a drawer connection between
io and fhe that you can view that
sub-exponential io implies fhe except
that we need a little bit more which is
the randomizability part which you will
see why it comes into play
from secrets
i tried they didn't work out for me i
mean someone else can
all right so
what do we want when we try to fast get
a probabilistic program okay
first of all i want to turn so the
paradigm now becomes i want to turn the
probabilistic program
into an unintelligible and deterministic
one okay
but i still want to say it preserves
functionality so what does that mean i
cannot say that this deterministic
program i'll put the same thing because
there isn't any single thing so to
preserve to say preserving functionality
i'll require the output distribution to
be indistinguishable okay
and in particular on the left hand side
the distribution is going to be taken
over the randomness of the probabilistic
program
on the right hand side since it's a
deterministic program there isn't really
any randomness so the randomness is
actually the randomness used by the
investigator at the time of producing
this vasculated program
as you see
it's not enough because i'm only
considering one single input what about
the joint distribution of outputs from
different inputs
and as you can see that since
the first key program is deterministic
it's easy to distinguish if
one gets the output for the same input
twice
so the strengths and the correctness is
that you should not be able to tell
apart and adverse you cannot teleport
whether you're getting output from p or
you're getting output from the first key
program provided that he does not ask
the same input twice
so this is as much as we can achieve
with correctness
so the more interesting thing is of
course security what can i get
well playing i o tells me that if two
deterministic programs are functionally
equivalent
meaning that they agree on every input
then the investigation should be
indistinguishable
now when we move to probabilistic
programs functional equivalence doesn't
exist
intuitively i would want to say that the
program should be functionally
indistinguishable okay think about that
i want to say program p is producing
encryption of zero and program q is
producing encryption of one okay if the
bursary have no secret key then i want
the first kd program to be
indistinguishable
well the intuition is it's very it's a
very natural
line of thoughts except the function
indispensability turns out to be not so
easy to define
and they're meant you can define it in
many different ways and every notion of
functional indistinguishability will
give you a corresponding notion of pio
the question is which makes sense and
whether for corresponding one does it
exist or not
so we can try to start again following
the natural line of thoughts and start
with defining one notion
so here i'm going to consider a sampler
which is going to sample a pair of
program p and q and some auxiliary
information
and our code is simpler dynamically
indistinguishable if the following two
games are indistinguishable
here the diversity is given
the tuple sampled from the distribution
in both words
and he can dynamically choose the input
and for that input he gets to see the
output of the program either from p or
from q
and uh the randomness is generated at
random in both games
so
well it seems
reasonable will require that the view of
the diversity should be
indistinguishable and this
indistinguishability will give me a
notion of pio
which is for any such pair of programs
the fascination should be
indistinguishable
seems very natural but it turns out that
if you just look carefully that
when i restrict the p and q to be
deterministic
this notion actually exactly collapsed
down to different input io
so therefore it suffers from some
impossible to result
this is seems to be a little bit
stronger than what we want because what
we want is something that is more closer
to io rather than the io
so what that means that i actually need
to consider stronger
indistinguishability
by making the indistinguishability
stronger and makes the premise stronger
and therefore make the pile notion
actually weaker
intuitively because you know the
attacker explicitly provides input so
something if you can distinguish you can
find which input is that claim exactly
the public coin variant will also be the
same thing
probably variant i guess we're
corresponding to that this auxiliary
information is going to contain
randomness for sampling p and q is that
right
is it meaningful then i mean because
there is no possibility there is
supposedly no impossibility results for
public points would be useful notion
it's a reasonable notion but we didn't
study the power of it
is
yeah so pio is even gen more general
than the i o this notion of pio
is more general than the i o because it
considers randomized programs
okay
all right so how can i strengthen this
indistinguishability
i'm going to make two simple
modifications to the previous game the
first modification is that instead of
letting the bursary choose the input
dynamically i ask him to choose it
statically
turns out that if i do this that should
make the indistinguishability weaker
okay so i could also consider a pil
notion corresponding to this
indistinguishability notion
but that is going to become impossible
so to actually strengthening it i will
require that the view of the diversity
in those two games
to be
extremely indistinguishable okay the
distinguishing gap is tiny tiny how tiny
it's negligible over x where x is the
number of inputs
in many programs you can imagine the
number of inputs is going to be
something exponential which means that
these two games are exponentially
inversely exponentially
indistinguishable
what is computational
something multiplied by x it reminds me
all right so
what did you say so before you introduce
this very very indistinguishable very
strong distinction
right so if i consider for any
distribution
that
are computationally indistinguishable
and i require that the investigation for
such distribution to be
indistinguishable that also give me a
notion of pio right and that notion is
impossible
why is it impossible to achieve
for the same reason as impossibility for
differing input or is this some um
i i
i can tell you about the proof which
isn't hard but i just don't have it on
top of my mind yeah you can't say
whether it's like the db re-typing
possibility or the dio type of
possibility pvp type it's
unconditionally impossible yeah there
exists actual distributions that satisfy
this indistinguishability that you can't
help their pio are indistinguishable
yeah no matter how you first get
all right so
given this very very very strong
indistinguishability let's leave it
aside how
reasonable it is
i can record that for such distribution
of fasciculation are indistinguishable
and this gives me a very very very weak
pill notion
and it seems really arbitrary right
people probably are like gazing at the
what is negligible over x in
distinguishability turns out this gap is
tight in fact if you relax this gap to
say that the two words are the gap of
the two words is less than one over
more than one over x then this notion
becomes impossible
so essentially this is necessary this is
the only thing we can achieve i mean
alternative incomparable options would
be required statistical
indistinguishability is negligible is
this notion useless like statistically
impossible statistically close
it's not uh you can
it's not useful in some sense
you cannot unconditionally argue
statistical distance
you can but usually i feel in that case
you can probably use io instead
because why do we want to consider those
computational indistinguishabilities we
want to use crypto inside
if you have some crypto that is
statistically secure then with some
effort you can just use io basically
x is the number of inputs right x is the
number of inputs
anyway
for any of the functionality yes but
adversary is ppt
so you can
k
why is that statistical
why isn't that statistical well
if i have sub-exponential encryption for
example
by making the security parameter large
enough i will be able to have a
computational distinguishing gap smaller
than the number of inputs
that's computation though the number of
random coins can be much bigger than x
it can get much bigger than log x
so in particular for example if i if i
was using it only for encryption of bit
encryption then x is just two right
um right
the input to your first gd program right
okay so it's great that people are
asking questions but i'm worried about
my time
because if some of you are at tcc can
remember that i was
there was a second half of my talk that
wasn't covered in the talk under the
careful watch of shai so i was hoping
that i would be able to go over that
all right so
as you can see a little bit already that
this notion how to define pio is intro
intricately related with which notion of
indistinguishability you consider and
there are many different notions you can
consider so in the paper we actually
name a few different variants and we
study the relationship between them
and
i'm going to only focus on xpio and i
will show you next that this is one of
the weakest bearing you could consider
and this is implied by sub-exponential
okay
and the construction proof is extremely
simple all right so what is the
construction
we're given with
a sub-exponential io and we want to
first get probabilistic program p
what else can i do
i'm going to first de-randomize this
probabilistic program using a similar
random function a punctuable one
and then i'm going to first give this
the randomized program okay so just as
anybody would do it
and let's see whether this is actually
secure
as a thought experiment
let's assume that the p and q have only
one input
and since they only have one input i
require the output distribution to be
indistinguishable okay and to show that
now this construction pio is actually
going to be indistinguishable i just
need to look at
the i o of the randomized version
and the proof is really one liner okay
since the programs have only one input
well i might well just hardware the
output since there's only one input
right
so how are the outputs which looks like
this what they are they're essentially
the output of the original program using
some sort of random coins
and since the prfs are indisputable i
might well just hardwire a randomly
sampled output
and now because the outputs are
indistinguishable
we have a bridge
therefore if there were only one input
in fact even io suffices for this
construction
we don't need the punctuable for this
single input one yeah but when you go to
multiple inputs
well what do we do we're gonna start to
look at an exponential number of hybrids
where the number of hybrids is the same
as the number of inputs and as you can
imagine that we're going to start from
one end which is the first question p to
another end with your first equation of
q and we're going to kind of graduate
more of those programs one input at a
time so if i look at the two neighboring
hybrids
they're gonna divide
which program to use to evaluate the
input
in a kind of just one step at a time so
in neighboring hybrids the two programs
are fascinated actually only differ on
one input okay in this particular case
they differ at input i
and therefore essentially the same proof
works out as before
but as you can see that our needs
something much stronger in order to
absorb the effect of this exponential
number of hybrids in particular i would
need io to be sub-exponential and i
would need the output distribution to be
more
indistinguishable than the inverse
of the number of inputs
with that the proof goes through
and that's why with sub-exponential io
we will get xpio
all right so the next thing is well
okay fine but this seems a very
restrictive notion two minutes only
oh gosh
i think i can finish that yeah
all right so but didn't i start a little
village
all right so
we have this nice dream that how about
what if i can it would be nice that if i
can take any cpa encryption scheme and
just transform it in a generic way into
a fhe right and i wouldn't need to learn
lattices i wouldn't need to
do any of that
and the hope is that maybe with the very
powerful tool pio i can do that it turns
out that we're just a little bit short
from that goal that we need the cpa to
have some additional property which will
be randomizable okay
and as a natural progression now we're
going to first achieve
level the homophobic encryption and then
go from there to fhe
so the two the second step from rht is
actually an independent transformation
and here we just need to work we can
work with any rhe with fixed decryption
depth in other words
i can actually turn any of those lwe
based le tree scheme into a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme assuming
slightly super polynomial secure i o
without any circular security assumption
okay so and i think that this is of
independent interest
fortunately since i met only give me
three minutes so
we're not gonna go over that in this
talk
all right so just the first part
and the construction is again extremely
natural what am i going to do with the
leg just like all constructions i'm
going to attempt to enable homomorphic
evaluation layer by layer right
to do so i'm going to associate with
each layer a pair of keys and if i look
at
a nand gate at a certain layer the
homophilic evaluation is going to derive
the ciphertext of the wire values under
the public key
at the layer i minus one and it will
attempt to try to get the ciphertext of
the output wire under the next the
public key of the next layer okay
well the most the most natural idea to
construe to enable this step is i'm just
going to a fascinator program that takes
into cipher text he's going to decrypt
it using a secret key for that layer and
then compute the nand and re-encrypt
okay
that's like everybody would like this
paradigm to work out because that's
really natural
so now think about whether the bursary
so
whether the verse 3 is going to get in
the end or you can think about what the
system is going to release in the end is
going to release the public keys
and then he's going to
the diversity at some point is going to
gather encryption of some random bit b
and he
as a part of system is going to get a
list of evaluation keys one per layer
and i want to argue that
the secret bit b is hidden okay what
else can i do that i have to rely on the
cpa security of the public key scheme
itself but except i can't really
immediately do that because those
evaluation keys contains lots of secret
keys inside okay so i cannot really rely
on the
semantic security of the
pk0 for example
only validation key one kind of contains
decryption here right evaluation key one
contains that right so in some sense i
want to eliminate the secret key in
evaluation key one but in order to do
that i will end up
needing to
eliminate all sacred keys in order
evaluation key okay
so
let's start with trying to do this
process of eliminating the secret key
from the last layer
let's look at the last layer evaluation
key
it does what it does decryption compute
and encrypt right
and
how about i just
instead of first getting that i'm gonna
first get in this toy circuit which does
nothing except your friend just encrypt
zero and output that
and the idea is that well
because actually the secret key for the
last public key appears nowhere
because after the last layer i don't
need to further homomorphically evaluate
therefore i don't need to decrypt the
last layer public key the secret key
appears nowhere therefore the output of
those two circuits are actually
indistinguishable
therefore by pio their investigation
should also be indistinguishable
oh great once i have done that in some
sense i've turned the second last
evaluation key to the last evaluation
key because the secret key doesn't
appear anywhere therefore i can just do
this hybrid and you know backwards
switch and all the evaluation keys one
by one i eliminate all the secret keys
inside now ta-da this cipher text is
hiding okay
great
except that there's a problem the
problem is that
the fact that this pio only work with x
indistinguishable distributions comes
into the way that it will make the size
of those evaluation keys bro up
why
because if i look at one intermediate
evaluation key
to argue that in order to apply pio i
actually need
their output distribution to be
very very very indistinguishable
how it's negligible over the number of
inputs
therefore
it means that for each of the evaluation
key our need the size of the output
cipher text to be way bigger
than the input
cipher text
because that's necessary
if that's the case well too bad
if i just start with evaluation key one
the ciphertext blow up a little bit the
outputs effort has brought up a little
bit which becomes the input for the next
evaluation key it blew up even more and
then
it grows exponentially there's only a
constant number you need though
oh i the number of electric evaluations
depends on the depth of your circuit
but the increase is just additive is it
you're saying it has to be
multiplicative it's
multiplicative
right
because that your
together one over x in
distinguishability gap you actually need
the size of the encryption to be pulling
yeah
all right
that's why we don't achieve
the dream
and we need something a little bit more
which is
i'm gonna actually start with using what
we call this kind of perfect lossy
public key
so this kind of public encryption has
two modes of the public keys one is a
normal mode which is like any cpu
encryption scheme the other is the
trapdoor mode which actually has perfect
hiding property and no correctness
requirement at all okay it's because
that it doesn't have any correctness
requirement that's why perfect hiding is
possible and note that i cannot work
with just any lossy public key
encryption scheme i actually need it to
be perfect the hiding property is
perfect it isn't enough to just to be
statistical
and this can actually be constructed if
i have randomizable public encryption
scheme
also you can base it on two messages
which is uh
perfectly secure for the sender this is
strictly more general i see okay
thanks for letting us know let me know
okay
all right so let's see that why does
this help
basically what it helps is that instead
of letting this
security loss happening inside those
hybrids i'm going to make the security
loss happen before outside it
even before i start switching all the
evaluation keys i'm going to switch my
public key to the trapdoor mode
once i have switched the public into the
trapdoor mode note that all those public
keys are going to be
perfectly indistinguishable no matter
it's
encrypting whatever value or encrypting
0.
now i can go through
all those hybrids i have done before
without any problem and without any size
blow up but is the uh evaluation circuit
still well defined is this is that snan
circuit still well defined when they
yes
yeah so there's still some secret key so
that still thinks it's decrypting things
ah so you will have to
okay i cheated a little bit you cannot
really switch the trap doors right
beforehand because there are many public
keys right there are many public keys
one per evaluation circuit so what you
need to do is switch the public key and
then do the indistinguishability step
and then switch the second public key to
the indistinguishability step
so it's kind of interleaved
not happening at the beginning
0 times exponentially still zero that's
that's the point so you're saying this
the point is that i want the output
distribution to be very very
indistinguishable if it's perfectly
indistinguishable meaning that their
identical distribution
that then it satisfies my
requirements you avoid the size 12
because it's zero okay
right
right
so i don't necessarily need it to be
zero i just want to say that the gap is
really small independent of the size of
the input yeah it's real yeah
let me leave it there i made this
already but thank you very much
for letting me finish